à 50 ans hakim qui recoupe dirige sa
propre centrale de taxi pour ce
strasbourgeois impossible d'imaginer sa
ville sans le parlement européen la
bataille du siège il connaît il ya 17
ans déjà quand je suis arrivé le premier
soir j'y travaille et il y avait
parlement déjà là j'entendais des gens
tendaient des choses en disant que le
parlement va partir voilà 17 ans après
le parlement est toujours là la semaine
où le parlement est là c'est vrai qu'il
ya plus de monde ça bouge plus voilà
751 eurodéputés leurs assistants de
nombreux fonctionnaires et interprète en
tout quelques 3000 personnes travaillent
ici quatre jours par mois
car le parlement ne se réunit à
strasbourg que pour les sessions
plénières le reste du travail
parlementaire se fait à bruxelles 317
jours par an le bâtiment reste vide
coûts annuelle de la transhumance 114
millions d'euros de quoi faire grincer
des dents sur le plan de l'efficacité
financière l'efficacité du travail ça
n'a pas beaucoup de sens d'avoir un
parlement qu'à 140 km2 des autres
institutions européennes et donc il y
aurait un intérêt à tout centraliser à
bruxelles alors bien sûr on pourrait
tout centraliser à strasbourg mais là le
coût du déménagement serait vraiment
astronomiques et donc franchement ce
n'est pas ce n'est pas réaliste de plus
les allers retours incessants entre
strasbourg et bruxelles roger très près
de 19 mille tonnes de co2 dans
l'atmosphère pour bart staes du parti
vert européen
cet éparpillement géographique n'est
plus tenable ça coûte énormément
d'argent c'est une perte de temps il
faut voyager et c'est pas bien pour pour
l'environnement si on veut faire quelque
chose en faveur du climat peut-être
qu'on pourrait essayer de trouver un
arrangement
un arrangement tout pourrait faciliter
le break site en avril dernier bart
staes ray une proposition rapatriés de
londres à strasbourg l'agencé européenne
du médicament et ses 8000 agents en
échange le parlement irait à bruxelles
pour les français c'est hors de question
en aucun cas on peut imaginer un troc
d'âge ans contre le parlement européen
s'est pas envisageable le parlement à
strasbourg mais ça correspond à une
certaine idée de l'union européenne
c'est l'europe des citoyens ceux qui
sont opposés à ce parlement à strasbourg
ont très souvent une autre vision l'idée
d'une europe qui se concentre uniquement
sur le marché commun l'europe économique
ou financière pour jouer la proximité le
parlement vient d'inaugurer un nouvel
espace à disposition des visiteurs
je clique sur anne secondaire j'ai son
activité parlementaire
j'ai les infos des tweets etc et puis
surtout j'ai la possibilité d'envoyer un
message directement aux parlementaires
strasbourg où l'europe des citoyens
contre l'europe du marché l'argumentaire
est bien rodé catherine trautmann a été
maire de la ville et députée européenne
entouré d'élus locaux elle organise la
riposte contre les anti strasbourg et
trois capitales européennes à savoir
bruxelles capitale exécutive luxembourg
capital juridique strasbourg capitale
parlementaire si le triangle
institutionnel qui permet l équilibre
des pouvoirs un triangle institutionnel
qui a ses limites car contrairement à
bruxelles la capitale alsacienne a pas
d'aéroport international
il n'est pas facile de venir de bucarest
à strasbourg
j'ai des responsabilités politiques dans
mon pays et ça m'empêche de prendre le
seul vol direct qui par le lundi matin
et rentrer le jeudi soir
autre point noir le logement pendant des
semaines de session c'est la flambée des
prix
les hôtels multiplient leurs tarifs par
quatre nos problèmes c'est quoi c'est
l'accessibilité ça engage la
responsabilité d'état à nos côtés et
c'est aussi je dois le dire parfois les
députés rouspète je les comprends c'est
le prix des hôtels pour lesquelles j'ai
toujours voulu que nous puissions avoir
un tarif de cession beaucoup plus
abordable pour les assistants et pour
nenê j
jeudi après midi fin de la parenthèse
strasbourgeoise valentina assistante
parlementaire travaille pour une députée
suédoise elle vit à bruxelles et ça fait
quinze ans qu'elle fait la navette moi
j'ai trois enfants et
jour mon mari aussi il va voyager pour
le travail donc on doit toujours bien
s'organiser quand il ya la session on ne
peut pas voyager c'est se rendre
vraiment le travail peu moins efficace
c'est plus difficile pour les
parlementaires
comme tous les mois un thalys
spécialement affrétés par le parlement
européen ramène les députés chez eux à
bruxelles
pour chaque personne qui sait là ça on
sait
la caravane parlementaires se remette en
route les députés reviendront dans un
mois un parlement deux sièges tant que
c'est à strasbourg que ce vote les lois
de l'europe ce va-et-vient n'est pas
près de s'arrêter